uh okay so let's do a quick review of uh
uh previous lecture
um I'm gonna do it on the slide here
because I think that that the picture is
a nice summary of uh where we're at so
we finished uh we are still now in the
process of developing the full DSP chain
for fmcw radar uh where we are at right
now is so far uh we've learned how to do
range estimation and velocity estimation
for fmcw
radar and basically developed a
so-called range velocity map which is
not the the geometric map that we
ultimately want but it is called a map
nevertheless and this picture also for
now we are assuming a single input
single output as ISO system today we are
going to generalize this to uh mimo but
the way the DSP works is that uh
remember we Define a frame
which is basically a number of
consecutive chirps that are transmitted
so we took basically we take M chirps
and call that a frame of data
and this is essentially like what what
uh uh makes a frame is entirely up to
whoever is developing the DSP uh to
Define that it's it's just you know a
mathematical construction of you take a
number of chirps and then you call that
a frame
um and then here we are basically uh
this picture shows how we process one
frame of data that that we have uh
collected so a frame has M chirps and
each chip or actually the the down
converted version of each chip after you
know mixing the received Echo with the
transmitted waveform and passing it
through the ADC each chip would have n
samples
and complex samples right so one frame
of data overall we can think of it or we
can rearrange it as a m by n data Matrix
and this is all in DSP right so that's a
raw data Matrix one frame and uh so
horizontal axis you can think of it as
index n which is the ADC samples and
vertically so each row is a one down
converted chip so the row index gives
you the chip index and then the column
index gives you the ADC sample number
okay and so our if signals we denote
them by two indices m and n and uh the
range on Doppler processing it's uh very
simple right so it's basically two
Fourier transforms
um you can first do it uh row wise you
can do them in any order really uh
doesn't matter but usually uh we first
do the range processing so you uh take
the fft of each row
and that converts basically your ADC
samples index and to a range index K and
that fft output we call them or we
denote them as artillies so artillery of
K basically would have uh if you if you
plot the basically the magnitude of of
each row at this point they would show
Peaks at K indices that correspond to
the range of uh the targets that that we
received Echoes from
um so that's the range processing step
and then for Doppler processing we do
another you know set of Fourier
transforms this time on The Columns of
this so we have ffd each column and then
at the output the final output that what
that second fft does for us it basically
converts the chip in XM to a Doppler
shift index l
and the output of the ffts we denoted
them as detailed these detailed efl so
these detailed these if you look at the
magnitude of those would show Peaks at
indices that correspond to the Doppler
shift of individual targets so because
the two are multiplied so you see what
we get out is like rtld of K times dtld
of L right the two are multiplied so if
you look at this uh basically process
data Matrix now or if you look at the
amplitude of it because it's complex
valued you take the absolute value of
each cell basically and now you now we
get a
what we call a range velocity map and if
you visualize it as you can visualize it
as a heat map or you can visualize it as
a 3D surface plot but what's important
about it is that just by looking at it
you can very clearly identify where you
have Targets in the scene not in terms
of the angle of arrival yet but in terms
of range and velocity so wherever you
have you know peaks in this range
doppler map like this and here color
corresponds to the the magnitude of the
process data so where you have basically
hot zones or Peaks those are targets so
here we have like a moving Target at say
20 meters and maybe
I'm just guessing the numbers maybe like
minus 20 meters per second or something
like that and then you have a bunch of
stationary Target targets at different
ranges and all at zero uh velocity
so that's how uh we do the processing
again um uh the the two steps the two
Fourier transforms uh there's different
ways you can do them you can either do
them as you know individual
one-dimensional Fourier transforms you
can do them in any order or you can
combine the two and just do it a 2d for
your channel so mathematically these are
all basically the same operation so you
can also uh uh basically summarize it
and just just a few uh basically
functional steps so again you take one
frame of data you accumulate the if
signals in an M by n Matrix and then you
do a 2d Fourier transform so this is now
combined range and Doppler processing
you get what we call the big Sif of lnk
so now remember L is the index for
Doppler K is the index for range and
then you look at the magnitude of s i uh
the the processed s and do like a 2d
Peak search and that gives gives you
basically range and velocity of course
you need to convert the indices to the
physical range and the physical velocity
and that's just a scaling that we have
seen before and here's a visualization
in in this case the range velocity map
instead of visualizing it as a as a 2d
heat map or image we're plotting the
full 3d surface so now the the height is
basically the the absolute value or the
magnitude of this basically output of
the 2D fft and just by looking at it in
this case it's very clear you can just
see two peaks and that means two Targets
right but usually in reality it's it's
you know it's much noisier than this and
it's it's uh they can you can have many
many Targets in the scene so then we
started talking about this idea of
Target detection right so Target
detection
uh
what what you're doing with it is
basically after processing for range and
Doppler we want to identify uh
uh which you know combinations of which
range and Doppler indices have actual
Target in them because as you see here
most of it is just noise right there's
nothing here nothing here there's just
really two Targets and the simplest
thing you can do is reset just a fixed
threshold you know you just like set a
threshold value you say like okay
anything higher than say 30 DB
um I'm going to declare that as a Target
right in simple cases that works
reasonably but in in reality it's it's
not
um a very effective technique because as
we said uh your noise can vary over time
there can be interferences that you know
shift the noise floor so you need a more
robust technique and then we started
talking about this idea of constant
false alarm rate or C4 thresholding and
what C4 thresholding effectively does
and we'll look at the mass today is
instead of a fixed Global threshold you
basically per cell and what I mean by a
cell is for each k and l
you calculate a uh a threshold that
corresponds to that cell and then you
compare the value of your processed
range doppler map at each combination of
K and L to the threshold that you
calculated with C4 for that cell if it's
above it you say there's a Target if
it's below it you say that's just noise
and the idea of C4 here is like if I
look at just just a 2d slice of this so
as a function of say range
if I plot this where there is a target
so it's mostly noise and then there's
one Peak and then there's also noise so
the idea of C4 basically is it's very
simple it's like so for each cell let's
like say where there is actually a
Target if you want to calculate a
threshold
um just exclude a few samples around it
and that's called a a guard band
basically and then
for some small window outside that guard
average the samples outside and the idea
is because the range doppler map as you
see here is typically sparse if you do
this if there's real Target in the cell
under test what's outside there is just
noise and you average those cells and
that gives you an idea of noise floor
right and then you can use that or a
scaled version of that to set a
threshold for your cell under test
that's basically the idea of C4 which
we'll look at in more detail today but
any questions before we
continue there's this idea of phrase
Doppler processing clear
okay so let's uh let's start looking at
C4
um so first we look at the 1D case and
then we extend it to 2D so again uh in
1D case we just have one index let's say
n uh and then for every n and for a
given signal uh you want to calculate a
a threshold okay
um so we call and the cell under test
and then there's three parameters
associated with the C4 algorithm there's
NG which is the number of guard cells
there's NT which is number of training
cells and then there's a gain factor of
beta and what you do is is very very uh
simple actually so what you do is here
let's look at the picture so this is
your your 1D signal so each Square here
is like one sample of your signal okay
and then you have this green cell this
is the cell under test so we are here
calculating the C4 threshold value for
this green cell okay as I said what you
do is that you first exclude a number of
guard cells on each side so here we have
chosen NG equals to just ignore the
yellow cells and then outside that on
each side you take
NT which is the number of training cells
that's uh we have chosen that to be four
in this case and you average all the
blue the values of all the blue cells so
you have this averaging block just feed
it all the the training cell values and
that output you can also scale it by
some scale factor beta beta is just a
number and that gives you the C4
Threshold at at the cell under test and
then and then you move that right so so
so then you do it for the next cell and
then you do it for the next cell so this
entire window basically shifts and then
you would calculate basically a per cell
threshold for the entire signal Vector
okay
so visually this is a a comparison of uh
fixed versus C4 thresholding let's look
at the top picture first so here we are
looking at one slice of the of the
processed signal after range Doppler
processing so that's a 1D case so as a
function of n the blues are signal okay
and then it has three very large Peaks
those are real targets those are the two
positives that we want to detect and
everything else is the noise if you use
a fixed threshold and that's this red
line here as you see
you can detect the true positives but
also there's this little guy here which
is a noise Peak and that if you're a
fixed threshold is low it can basically
stick above the noise and that you would
also detect that as a Target which would
be a false positive now let's look at
the bottom picture and that's what C4
would do for the same signal so here the
red is this the per cell C4 threshold
that we have calculated and we have
chosen uh five uh basically a number of
guard cells and training cells is 20 and
the scale factor is six okay and now if
you look at this C4 threshold it has
this very interesting behavior that
where you have a large Peak just outside
it it will go up and that's because at
some point this this peak would make it
into the training cells and and that
basically biases the value of the C4 but
if I zoom in where the actual Peaks are
the C4 threshold is actually pretty
close to our fixed threshold this
lighter blue is our old fixed threshold
so it does a good job of detecting the
true positives and also if you look at
this noise guy it doesn't make it above
the C4 threshold so it also does a good
job of rejecting the false positive now
you might ask okay but how did you come
up with these numbers it's like the 520
and the six and there is different
techniques but usually you know you you
collect a few data sets and you kind of
you know try different values on them
and tune these parameters until you get
satisfactory uh false positive rates and
then just just use them in the field so
that's that's usually how it is done uh
very uh in a very straightforward manner
you can extend this to two Dimensions
you can do the exact same thing because
remember our arrange Doppler process
signal is a 2d signal so you can do 2D
as or you can actually do n dimensional
C4 it's the same idea so in 2D here's
the picture ignore the math for now
let's just look at the picture so now
you have this
2D basically signal could be our the
magnitude of our range Doppler process
signal and then again you have a guard
you have a a a basically
um
cell of interest
and then you define some number of guard
cells so you exclude the yellows
right outside that and then you have
some number of training cells so you
basically for each cell under test you
average all the blue cells
and scale the average by Beta and that
would give you the C4 threshold value
for that cell and then you do that for
for every cell so you just you know
shift it and shift it until you cover
the entire 2D uh signal the math above
uh it I mean it kind of looks
complicated but it's it's really nothing
so beta is just your scale factor this
big expression down here really just all
that is is the number
of
training cells that really is what it is
I mean it's in terms of like NG and NT
but really that's just uh so that's one
over the number of training cells times
the sum of your signal over all training
cells so this would give you the average
this term is the average over the
training cells
average of your signal over the training
cells and then you multiply by Beta
that's your scaling Factor it gives you
your C4 threshold so that's how you do
2D and you can extend it to to ND you
can even make it asymmetric you know if
you're if you need like more guard cells
very quickly than horizontally you can
have two different I mean you can make
all sorts of variations of this but this
is the core idea and if you look at the
literature there's like 10 different
versions of seafarers like C4 cows C4
this C4 that but they're all you know
little variations of this this basically
uh basic idea now
um so so so with this this would work
much better than applying a fixed
threshold and uh if if you do this with
correctly tuned parameters on uh the
magnitude of your uh range velocity map
it would nicely detect uh the targets
for you yes
previous one this
are really close to each other then
uh I can't see if I detect there like
yeah that's a great question so if you
have multiple pieces so if if these
Three Peaks were closely packed right so
I'm gonna just sketch it here so if if I
had something like a peak and another
Peak and another Peak and another Peak
what would C4 do uh if you tune it right
it can handle that uh so so with that
what what that means is that you want to
increase probably your NG number of
guard cells so so that can then handle
you know wider you know collect a peak
that is very wide or a collection of
Peaks that are very tightly packed
um
today this not the best algorithm out
there it's it's pretty good it can do
much much better than fixed threshold
but I mean these algorithms are again
really everything we we talk about here
we're talking about like the most basic
thing that you can do which is very
mathematically efficient but these days
like if you if you think in terms of
like modern algorithms you can come up
with much much better you know
algorithms to do this you can even think
uh I mean go down the path of uh you
know learned algorithms like I don't
know train like a neural network that
does this for you and that would beat
like see far by I'm sure a wide margin
um so so I mean yes there's definitely
Corner cases where C4 can fail it's not
a perfect algorithm but you know today
it's widely used and it's very efficient
but again everything we talk about
especially for radar just give take
these as you know not this is how it
should definitely be done this is one
way of doing it it's the simplest thing
it's what is being done today but always
think of especially if you have more
compute resources at your disposal on
the system you're working with you
should absolutely do you know more
sophisticated better algorithms there's
no way to just because we talked about
C4 here always do that okay
so that's C4 so where are we now so so
far from uh for and and C4 by the way
like this target detection this is
completely independent of like is it
pmcw radar is it FMC like what waveform
was used does not matter because at the
end of the day you do your range and
Doppler processing you produce these
range Doppler or range velocity maps and
then this idea of Target detection would
work on it doesn't care uh what the
actual underlying waveform was
okay so we can do estimate range we can
estimate velocity we can detect targets
right and by detection I mean we can
find range and velocity combinations
that we are very confident there is a
real Target there the last step is how
do we determine the angle of the Target
or the direction of the arrival or the
bearing or the angle of there's
different terms in radar it's mostly
called DOA or direction of arrival so
that's the last step
um so it's the last DSP step and if we
do that like after we do angle of
arrival estimation then we can basically
completely localize our targets and and
and and in 3D right because we know the
range we know that Theta is the Azimuth
angle let's say Phi is the elevation
angle so every Target you can completely
localize where it is in the 3D space and
that means you can basically produce uh
the so-called radar image which could be
a 3D or a 2d Point Cloud okay so that's
the ultimate map that we want to produce
and this is the last step so when it
comes to DOA estimation there's two main
approaches
one is
um
if you have a highly directional antenna
and by highly directional antenna I mean
an antenna with a gain pattern that is
you know very narrow and focused okay if
you have that then you can mechanically
scan the antenna you can always assume
like the direction I'm pointing the
antenna if I detect anything that that
direction is is the DOA of my Target
because my beam is very focused okay so
you just mechanically scan the antenna
and by the angle you're pointing that
tells you the DOA of the target so
that's one
um but again you have to have a highly
directional antenna that's very
important uh or if you don't have a
highly directional antenna what you can
do is if you build a mimo array with
multiple transmitter and multiple
receiver antenna you can use a number of
techniques which are collectively called
beam forming techniques and that would
basically enable you to determine the
direction of arrival of the target what
beamforming techniques effectively do is
that
electronically they would kind of do the
same thing that the mechanical scanning
does with a very narrow beam so
electronically they basically change the
uh basically
beam pattern or the radiation pattern of
either your transmitter or your receiver
such that you can effectively search the
space and find where the target is so
that's generally what being forming
techniques do
and when it comes to autonomous robotics
uh uh pretty much
only beam forming methods are used and
the the mechanical scanning isn't used
for obvious reasons because to to have
highly directional antenna these are
physically very large like you need
these big dish antennas or things like
that and then they also need to you know
mechanically rotate and scan the scene
so they're big they're not very robust
for you know robotic applications
um it's just not the the right fit for
those for other applications mechanical
scanning is is widely used so for
instance for
Aviation you know you go to the airports
you see these parabolic antennas on the
side of the runways that are rotating
that's exactly what they're doing
they're mechanically scanning for for
DOA uh okay so what what to expect these
are just some pictures to so at the end
of the day if you do all this we do
range processing Doppler processing we
detect the targets we detect the DOA and
then we visualize you know all these
Targets in the form of a point Cloud
what can we expect from let's say a
state-of-the-art radar today so in terms
of the the DOA resolution uh better than
one degree is is achievable today I've
seen Radars
coding you know as low as as 0.4 degrees
and here are two examples one is a 3D uh
map produced by a radar so here on the
on the right uh you see a basically a a
picture of the scene so uh this this
white blue car that's where the radar
was mounted actually this is the radar
uh looking at the scene and there were
like two pedestrians marked by one and
two there was a row of cars here and uh
some other things and then on the left
you see the 3D radar image or the point
cloud or the map that was was uh was
produced uh so you see you know that the
two pedestrians here uh this is stuff
here that's the row of cars and you know
uh that's that's basically the quality
of of the map uh this one that we're
looking at here I think the resolution
is
um about one degree in Azimuth and 1.5
degrees in elevation and that's kind of
the quality of the point Cloud that that
you can get from it
um this one on the left uh on the right
this is a a a 2d Point cloud of a radar
so this was uh also mounted on a car and
this is like from the driver view this
is the camera image of of the car was
driving on the highway so you see the
the road boundaries and the things that
are numbered here you know a few of them
are cars you know there's one two three
four cars uh this one is like a big road
sign and a tree and then the point Cloud
uh this is 2D so we are showing it like
a bird's eye view top down view of of
off the road so this is the road
basically as seen from the top uh the
the ego vehicle was kind of like down
here and the visualization here is
interesting because they have also used
the velocity information to color the
point Cloud which is a very uh useful
thing to do so uh things that were
moving in the scene like the cars
they're colored in yellow so they easily
you know you you can see them so that's
like the three cars it actually sees
beyond the the ones immediately in front
of the car so there was another car here
another car out there that's the
incoming car on the other side of the
road so that's that guy uh you get the
the big tree all the vegetation on the
side you is obvious and then that's
probably the the big road sign so this
is kind of like qualitatively gives you
an idea of what to expect and these are
pretty much state of the art in terms of
like what's doable today for um for for
autonomy applications
this is uh one of the you know best
3D or 4D Radars out there same idea so
picture on the right that's aerial view
of the the the scene and where the point
Cloud was captured so that's the ego
vehicle where the the radar was mounted
on this it was driving on the road and
this uh one
uh boxed in blue that's a car that was
driving in front of them and then on the
right you see the radar image I think
for this one they used more than one
radar because they're also seeing behind
the car so it was probably like four
Radars mounted on the four sides of the
car so they can you know cover full uh
360 degrees but it's pretty impressive I
think for a radar I mean you clearly see
you know the the trees that's the road
and then the choice of colors is not
great but this purpley thing is the car
that was driving in front of them again
very qualitatively give you an idea of
what you can expect from this of course
not every radar would be this high
resolution I mean these have very big
mimo arrays like the one here had 48
transmitters 48 receivers
um so very large Mamo array and that
that helped them to basically with beam
forming techniques achieve this quality
of for Point Cloud so let's see uh how
beamforming works so again just to
summarize there's mechanical scanning
versus beam forming mechanical scanning
we're not going to talk about because
those are not used for autonomy but
here's an example you have a dish
antenna with a very highly directional
beam it hits a Target and basically the
angle that you were aiming so the Theta
Phi
that you were aiming that tells you the
DOA of the target so there is no DSP
basically when it comes to Mechanical
scanning you just read back where the
antenna was pointing to and call that
the DOA of the target versus in beam
forming you use a mimo antenna array the
one shown here has two transmitters six
receivers the antennas do not need to be
directional at all actually in theory
they can even be isotropic you know
physically isotropic is not possible but
they can be as close as isotropic as you
want and then with beam forming
techniques we basically electronically
search the space and find what the DOA
of the target is as we'll see today
now as I said beam forming is like a
collection of of techniques and broadly
they can be categorized to two basically
types of beam forming first one is the
so-called active transmitter beam
forming and in short it's called txbf
also called commonly phased array radar
or electronic beam steering
so what active transmitter beamforming
does basically is that it uses multiple
transmitter antennas and then it
controls the phase of the signal that is
being fed to these antennas and by
controlling that relative phase
effectively it can generate a very
narrow focused beam and scan it in in
the space exactly as if you were
mechanically scanning a highly
directional antenna
um I think perhaps if we look at a
little
um illustration of it it's it's more
clear so this is from Wikipedia so what
is what is done here
uh I don't have a cursor so I'll I'll go
on the projector
um so you have multiple transmit
antennas and here they're assuming the
antennas are isotropic you see like if
you look at each antenna the waveform
coming out is a spherical right but they
are basically applying a phase shift and
the notation here is not perfect but
what Phi is is the Delta phase between
every two consecutive antennas so you
can think of the first one as the
reference there's zero phase and this
one would be Phi this one would be two
five three four five six seven five
right so it's like a linear phase
difference and you can think of a phase
as like a little time delay also that
that that is being applied so there's
this controller that controls the phase
of the signals before being fed uh to
the antennas and by controlling that as
you see each of them is just
transmitting spherical waves but
effectively if you look at the wave
fronts at far field they're like a plane
wave that is pointing to a direction
Theta and by changing Phi you can
basically electronically scan the angle
or the effective angle of the of the
overall transmitted beam so
active transmitter beamforming
effectively scans The Beam for you as if
you had like a directional antenna with
with physical scanning here's another
very interesting picture it is showing
uh so this here if you read that the
description it says phase array of 15
antenna elements is spaced quarter
wavelength apart as the phase difference
between adjacent antennas is swept
between minus negative 20 120 degrees
and plus 120 degrees and that is
effectively like a scanning your Beam
for you with almost a full you know 180
degrees and this is a this is a
one-dimensional scanning you can do 2D
if your antenna elements are placed in a
2d array basically so that's the idea of
active transmit beam forming
and then the second type of beam forming
techniques is the so-called digital
receiver being forming or dbf uh digital
receiver beam forming is uh basically
here you use multiple receiver antennas
and jointly process the signals that you
get from the receive antennas and by
some clever DSP you effectively in
algorithms in DSP search the space to
find what the direction of arrival of
the target is so if you compare the two
um it's very interesting because in the
active transmit being forming it adds
complexity to the hardware you need
these phase controllers for every
transmitter antenna and then you know
you need to accurately apply uh time
varying phase shifts to them versus the
digital receiver beam forming there's no
Hardware complexity right you just need
an array of antennas and the complexity
goes to your algorithms instead right so
that's a trade-off on one hand you have
simple algorithms more complex hardware
for dbf you have simple Hardware but
more complex algorithms and math that
you can do and almost always when you
reach such a trade-off
it's the best decision is to go with the
solution which makes your algorithms
more complex why well first of all As We
Know compute day by day is becoming more
capable and cheaper okay so it's just a
from from that point of view if cost is
a concern it's always a good idea to
make your Hardware simpler and make your
algorithms more complex but also more
importantly if you go down the path of
you know go with the with the complexity
in the algorithms after you say like you
ship your Hardware you can keep
improving it by just by just software
updates right you can just a few months
down the road you come up with a better
algorithm you implement it you deploy it
and that sensor becomes better versus if
you go with the one that
is kind of like the complexity is in the
hardware it is what it is right like
after you ship it that Hardware forever
is going to be what it is until you
actually change the hardware build a new
one you can't really in algorithms do do
much about it so with these types of
trade-offs I'm a big advocate of go down
the you know path of uh uh um you know
the so-called software definedness
that's that's the industry term
basically
however in both of these are used in
robotic autonomy dbf is of course for
the reasons I said is is much more
common but both are used and off the
shelf Hardware usually has support for
both it does support active transmit
deforming and and dbf uh we're going to
talk a lot about this because again
that's the most widely used most
interesting thing and that's uh it's
just a space where you can for for years
to come you can keep you know uh coming
up with new ideas and and improving the
the sensor performance just by better
algorithms
okay so um
we are going to start talking about dbf
but just before that here's one one more
picture of uh a a very big phased array
uh antenna that is used for some
military application I think this one
might be like an early warning system or
something like that so uh this one I
mean it has many many antenna elements
actually each of these little squares
that you see here if you zoom in you get
this which itself has a big to the array
of antennas so it's a huge huge phase
array and then they can do very accurate
you know active transmit being forming
so phase array is is very commonly used
in you know military applications like
the uh very very beautiful examples like
the F-35 fighter jets uh they have this
super Advanced phased array antenna in
the nose of the of the airplane which
which can give them very accurate you
know uh radar DOA resolution okay but
the topic of discussion for today is uh
digital receiver beam forming or dbf so
again this is the idea where uh you just
use multiple receiver antennas
um with with some clever DSP you can
find the DOA of the target so so uh
before we can talk about the algorithm
as usually as usual we need to build a
signal model what is the signal model
that that that we we can work with so to
build a signal model we make a few
assumptions
so
um we assume uh for now one pair of txrx
antennas and located at R Prime TX and R
Prime RX so the the r primes are the
position of the TX and the RX antennas
uh correspondingly and let's assume
there is one target at the DOA angle
Theta
okay
um and uh we assume that the target is
in the far field okay so with that
assumption that the target is far field
so let's look at the picture down here
so the blue is our transmit antenna
Reddit is the receive antenna and assume
the target is like way out there so I'm
going to just put a dot at the corner
here so that's the Target that these
guys are kind of looking at if the
target is far away as we know we can
assume that the the the the the fields
that basically hit the target and Echo
back we can approximate them very well
with plane waves okay so uh the the
transmitted wave so that's the blue one
here we can write that as a plane wave
which uh it's the direction is going to
be determined by the K Vector of that
plane wave we call that KTX and it's
going to point towards the target so the
targeted at some DOA Theta so K is
pointing at an angle Theta
um uh to the to the right and the field
that we're transmitting is given by this
expression here let me clean it up
um
it's e to the minus J KTX R Prime TX so
this is the field at the end at the
transmit antenna times s t of T what is
St that's our basically transmitted
waveform you know if it's a fmcw radar
we know you know the SST X for fmcw is
going to be our e to the J 2 pi you know
FC plus slew rate times T over 2 T
that's for fmcw
if it's pmcw you put the pmcw waveform
in there but it doesn't what's nice is
it doesn't matter for this part of the
algorithm whatever waveform you use the
dbf will work for it this is the plane
wave right remember e to the minus J K
dot R defines a plane wave
that travels in the direction of the K
vector and has you know planar phase
runs uh what about the echoed Back Field
at the receive antenna that's also a
plane wave given by this expression e to
the minus j k r x times uh inner product
with the the position of the RX antenna
times the received waveform which as you
know is like attenuated delayed version
of the transmitter
um
what's important here is that if you
look at this picture the the two plane
waves the one that we transmit and the
one that we received are exactly in
opposite directions if the target is far
away so our krx
is minus KTX
that's an important assumption in the in
the algorithms that we will develop
is this clear the setup
okay so now what we can look at is that
if this is the field at the transmit
antenna and this is the field at the
receive antenna
um so as as you know I'm gonna clean
things up a little here
so it doesn't get too busy
and
as you know we talked a lot about these
two parts of the signal the temporal
part or the waveform part of it that is
transmitted and is received and we said
from from these after you know mix them
down together you get this gives you
this Sif right of T which is used for
range
and Doppler estimation or velocity
estimation and it has a frequency
component which gives us the range and
the phase of it gives us Doppler right
that's that's the range Doppler
processing we've already talked about
now we are looking at this part which uh
is basically a function of where the
target is and this is what I call the
spatial phase
it's not a technically correct term
but I think you get the point because
there is some temporal phase here which
gives us Doppler right but this term
here it has no time dependency it's only
has a space dependency or you know angle
dependency and and that phase term here
so what is the phase it's just this KTX
times R Prime TX and krx times or inner
product it with r Prime RX those are the
spatial phase terms so if we look at
that phase difference right the spatial
part of it call that Omega so we're
taking the phase difference which is
just the contributed to from the target
DOA Theta what is that so the phase that
the transmitter as we said is minus KTX
in our product with r Prime TX and the
phase that we receive is minus krx and
our product with the RX antenna position
and we're just subtracting the two to
get find that phase difference what it's
equal to and we use the fact that krx is
minus KTX so we can just write it in
terms of krx it becomes krx dot product
with r Prime RX plus r Prime TX remember
that the norm of the K vector
generally is always equal to 2 pi over
Lambda so this inner product we can
write it in terms of the norm of the
vectors and the angle between them it
becomes equal to this expression here
minus 2 pi over Lambda times the norm of
R Prime TX plus r Prime r x times sine
of theta this is very important right so
super important if I know the position
of my TX and RX antenna so if R Prime RX
R Prime t x are no which I always know
right because
I basically own that radar so I can you
know measure where the TX and RX
antennas are and then if I somehow
measure the phase difference between
um you know that that round trip signal
accumulated due to that difference in
the position of the TX and RX antenna so
if I know my Omega then I can find sine
Theta you just divide your Omega by by
this and then that's sine Theta and then
you take the arc sine and that gives you
your target DOA okay I mean technically
yes but that's not how it's done because
if you just rely your DOA estimation on
just one phase measurement it's going to
be very noisy and you don't get a very
good estimate but that's the core idea
here you kind of see where we are going
we're going to work with this phase term
Omega and perhaps look at more antennas
to get a more accurate estimate another
thing that is really important here and
really helps us to simplify our signal
model is that this phase it doesn't
depend on the individual positions of TX
and RX antennas it just depends on the
sum of the two right
so I can move my my TX antennas and RX
antennas but as long as that R Prime RX
plus our Prime TX that some position
doesn't change it wouldn't affect the
the face okay
so
um
now in a mimo system I'm going to have
multiple tx's and multiple rx's right so
you can look at any pair of transmit
receive antennas like transmit number K
transmit antenna number K send a
waveform and I'm receiving it on every
receive antenna so every pair of
transmit receive would give you one of
these omegas that you can you can
measure okay so mathematically if you
look at the if signal that is uh
received when the case transmitter was
transmitting and I'm getting it from a
receiver antenna number Q
then I can write that as Sif of KQ which
is equal to now I'm going to add the
indices to my Omega the Omega is also k
q so K is a transmit index antenna index
Q is the receive antenna index and in
terms of the position of the case
transmit antenna and Q uh uh receive
antenna I can explicitly write my if
signal in this form so it's e to the
minus J 2 pi over Lambda it's a function
of the sum of the positions of the
antenna transmit antenna q k receive
antenna Q sine Theta is again that's the
DOA of the Target that echoed back and s
i f of T is our good old down converted
trip waveform
okay and again the chip rate form if
it's fmcw if it's pmcw it's your code
word it does not matter for the purpose
of determining the DOA it does not
matter what this Sif is whatever it is
the algorithm works because we are going
to work with this part the part that the
term depends on Theta which there's no
contribution from the actual waveform to
it it only depends on you know the
geometry and the angle and the position
of the antennas make sense
okay so
um
one more thing that uh we made that
simplification but uh I want to point it
out because it's extremely important
here with this signal model
up up here we assumed the antennas are
perfectly isotropic okay because there
was no contribution to the from the gain
of the antenna basically we know in
reality antennas have gain patterns G of
theta which are not isotropic so in that
case all you need to do to make your
signal model complete is that you just
multiply it by G of theta you just
insert your G of theta in there and this
is your signal model for the case where
your antennas are not isotropic for the
rest of the derivation we are going to
assume G of theta is almost one so we're
going to go by the Assumption of
isotropic antennas but extremely
extremely important to remember if your
antennas are not isotropic you should go
back and you know plug in whatever G of
theta is and work with that signal model
super important again these assumptions
are what could completely make or break
your your application
Okay so so now consider a mimo array
let's say we have ntx transmit antennas
and nrx receive antennas okay so how
many if signals am I gonna have access
to it's going to be ntx times nrx
because every pair of txrx antennas will
give me an if signal right so or the
other way to think about it every
transmit antenna that transmits you're
going to get Echoes on all the receivers
through all gonna receive so so in total
you would get ntx times nrx pairs let's
call that P so p is ntx times nrx so
you're going to have a total of P if
signals after you look at all
combinations of of transmit and receives
and again I'm rewriting what we had in
the previous slide Sif of KQ for
transmitter K receiver Q is given by
this expression here e to the minus J 2
pi over Lambda times the norm of the
position of RX plus position of TX times
sine Theta times R good old down
converted if waveform
okay so again as you see even for the
case of the mimo if you look at this
term it does not determine that the
spatial phase does not depend on the
individual position of the TX and rxs it
only depends on the norm of the sum
okay so here's a very interesting
idea and this is a pure you know
mathematical simplification what we are
going to do here but it really really
makes the math more more tractable for
us so we are going to introduce this
idea of the virtual antenna array and
what the virtual antenna array is uh so
instead of working with these if signals
I can define a so-called virtual antenna
array which instead of having ntx
transmitters and nrx receivers it has
one transmitter
and ntx tons nrx receivers
this virtual array
and I can assume the transmitter is at
the origin is at position zero and these
and this is our P right these P
receivers each of them is at this
location which is the sum of the
transmit and receive and this this is
again this is a virtual antenna this is
like a mathematical construction but
with that
I can really simplify my math because I
can Define this virtual array which has
again a single transmitted that's
located at the origin so R Prime TX is
zero and it has P receiver antennas and
each receiver receiver number P is
located at the sum of the positions of a
TX and RX pair from the original
physical array okay and now if I work
with this virtual array I'm going to get
and write the basically the the signal
model for that I'm going to get the
exact same thing as this except the I'm
not I wouldn't need to like
keep writing R Prime TX plus r Prime RX
because R Prime TX is 0 and I just work
with the norm of the r Prime RX of the
virtual array okay so the effective P
element RX array is called the virtual
array let's see visually because I know
the math is you know too abstract here
so let's see visually what the what the
virtual array looks like so let's look
at the picture here so here we have a 2d
7 element mimo array so this is the
physical array it has three transmitters
tx1 tx2 tx3 and four receivers okay
so the idea of the virtual array is that
instead of this construct a a virtual
array that has just one transmitter
located at the origin and it would have
how many receivers it would have three
times four right ntx times nrx which is
12 receivers and each receiver you place
it at a position which is the sum of one
of the original t-axis plus one of the
original rx's so if you do that this
purple array is the effective virtual
array that you get okay so we basically
transform a mimo system with this trick
to a Simo system
single transmit multi-receive but the
number of receivers is that
ntx times nrx so it has actually more
elements than the the original physical
array okay
and in general if you want to be able to
detect a 3D direction of arrival so both
Azimuth and elevation you need an array
which expands to the N by 2D I mean you
need array Elements which are placed
both horizontally and vertically which
is the case here you see you have some
elements that span horizontally and then
you have two rows so you also have some
some vertical elements
um but it turns out that as you would
see when we are developing our DOA
algorithms so then you can find your
Azimuth angle Theta and elevation angle
Phi
but it turns out that the way the the
DOA processing algorithm works at least
the one that we develop here it works
completely independently in the Theta
and Phi Direction so it only looks at
you know the elements that are placed
horizontally to find your Azimuth angle
and it only looks at the elements that
are placed vertically or the relative
phase of them to find the elevation
angle so because of that so that the
math doesn't get you know too messy uh
we are going to just consider a 1D
virtual array for now an estimate just
Theta from it so that a notation doesn't
get too messy but the exact same idea
for a 2d array you apply it twice and
then you can find both Theta and Phi
okay so that's that's the thing
okay so let's summarize everything we
talked about and kind of you know go
over it one more time we have so far
only Built the signal model and this
concept of the virtual array but this is
a extremely important slide I think this
is perhaps the most important slide of
our entire radar chapter because it
really summarizes it's there's a lot of
things packed into this one page so I'm
going to go over it but but please
please make sure you spend a lot of time
you know really parsing out everything
that is noted here and make sure it all
makes sense it shouldn't be just math
right it should there should be meaning
assigned to every you know uh everything
that's that's that's written down here
but it's our it's our full signal model
and this will explain everything range
velocity DOA okay so and it's as general
as it gets so let's assume there is K
Targets in the scene okay different
targets in the scene that are echoing
back and then the if Sigma all from the
virtual array element p
okay so we are talking in the in the
virtual array space now the if signal
that you get from that Sif of P we call
that which technically is equal to like
if you want to write it in terms of the
physical array it would be Sif
of some combination KQ where K is the
transmitter and Q is the receiver what
is that equal to well it's the sum of
The Echoes from all K targets so that's
why we have some I from 1 to K and then
each Target contributes a spatial phase
that's this e to the J
Omega with two indices p and I I is the
target Index P is the antenna or the
virtual antenna index so that's the
spatial part of it and then the temporal
part is this s i f of T which is the
same thing we have talked about a lot
which is down converted waveform so
that's that but we are going to go one
level deeper what is omega omega p i
Omega Pi basically contains the
information about the DOA of the ice
target okay so if the DOA of Target
number I is Theta I uh
Omega pi and again p is one of our
virtual antennas so that's the signal
you get from one of those virtual
antennas Omega Pi is equal to this
expression which is minus 2 pi over
Lambda now we only have Norm of RTL D
Prime rxp because again we're talking
about the virtual antenna so instead of
like R Prime TX plus r Prime RX because
in the for the virtual array the TX is
zero I placed at zero you just get the
norm of RTL D Prime RX times sine Theta
so that is again what I call the spatial
phase
of the if signal
and then the temporal part of it is this
thing we have worked with a lot so
that's s i f of T is the if Echo
waveform from the I Target
that contains range and Doppler
information now this part depends on
what waveform you send if it's supposed
to fmcw was it pmcw was it something
else for fmcw last time we showed that
Sif is given by the sigma and this
expression here mu is the gain of the
the low noise amplifier Alpha I is the
attenuation factor for the ice target
then you get two complex exponentials
sorry there's one more thing there's the
this e to the J let me clean this
there's this e to the J Phi zero I which
is the phase at the start of the frame
right then you get this first complex
exponential which has Delta f i so this
will this is going to give you the range
of the I Target after you do the range
fft on it and then there's this second
term e to the minus J 2 pi f d AI which
is the the Doppler shift from the ice
target and this is going to give you the
relative radial velocity of the Target
and then how you map the frequencies to
the physical quantities velocity and
ranges is given here okay again it's a
very very information denser slide so
absolutely make sure at your own pace go
over it spend as much time as you need
and make sure everything makes sense and
by makes sense I don't mean like yeah
it's a summation and I know what like
the sign is by make sense I mean tie it
back to all the physical Concepts we
talked about and make sure you know you
can you can explain it in in words math
is like anyone can do math right but the
importance is like can you explain
what's behind the math and I want to
make sure that's that's clear if it's
not clear absolutely come talk to us we
can sit together you know go over it and
and make sure it makes sense
Okay so
now model
can we can talk about algorithms
right and specifically if I clean things
up
our algorithm for DOA estimation the dbf
is going to
focus on this term the spatial phase
because that contains the DOA
information and if we extract that we
are basically done okay one more thing
so as you see again I'm going to clean
this up a little bit when it comes to
this spatial first phase term Omega it
depends on two things one is the target
DOA that's the sine Theta I term but it
also depends on the antenna geometry or
the virtual antenna geometry and by
geometry I mean the positions of the
virtual elements go into it right so to
be able to develop an algorithm we need
to clarify what these RTD rxps are what
is the geometry of the virtual array
that we're working with we're going to
start with the simplest geometry you can
think of which is a so-called uniform
linear array or Ula what the Ula is and
again we're talking about the effective
virtual array that you get
what the Ula is is just all the virtual
elements are arranged linearly
in a line with constant spacing right so
this is what a Ula looks like you have
your RX1 rx2 rx3 all the way to RX
number P they're all on the line and for
now let's assume it's like horizontal
and the spacing between
H2 is some constant d right so with that
the norm of basically the position of
rxp Norm rtld Prime rxp is just equal to
the antenna index times d
right so you can say yeah this one is at
D this one is at 2D this one is at 3D
and so on or you can start at zero
doesn't matter okay
so that's what a Ula is and now with
that now we can talk about how we do DOA
okay now as I said the DOA step is the
last step in our DSP so we have already
done a range processing Doppler
processing we've detected the Target and
now we are going to find it's it's DOA
so the actual signal that would feed
into our DOA
DSP is the range Doppler processed if
signal okay so we are going to call that
our Sif previously was just the function
of lnk if you remember where L was the
Doppler index
and K was the range index
and we used to talk about siso systems
so there was only one antenna to work
with but now it's a mimo system so we're
going to add a third index which is
basically the virtual antenna index
that's the P right and we need that
because we are now talking about mimo
systems now what is this Sif it's range
Doppler process so we have done our 2D
fft on the little s p of M and N and as
we do after a range Doppler processing
what we get is basically our signal
becomes artillery I times dtdi so this
is the output after the two ffts but now
we are also including our spatial phase
term which is this guy e to the minus J
2 pi over Lambda P times D sine Theta I
so what this is this PD remember that's
just the norm of r t Prime rxp
okay so this entire this full term here
is just e to the minus J big Omega p i
that's the spatial phase term that we
had in our signal model
very good
um almost done almost done bear with me
for five more seconds farm from minutes
and we'll be done with the painful math
but here the way you should think about
the signal is previously for this ISO
case we were thinking in terms of
matrices right because we only had range
and Doppler index now we have range
index Doppler index and antenna index so
it becomes a cube basically so this guy
is called it's a it's a m by n by P
again Big M is the number of chips in a
frame Big N is the number of samples ADC
samples per chip
p is the number of virtual antenna
elements and this is called a
pre-processed radar data Cube why
pre-process because we have already done
range Doppler processing on it okay
that's why it's pre-processing before it
it's called raw radar data Cube I'll
show some pictures to clarify but one
more step before we do DOA remember we
do Target detection like C4 or constant
thresholding what that does that does
for us is that it extracts the range and
Doppler indices we call that L hat i k
hat I or the range and Doppler Peak
indices for the ith Target okay so once
you do that because if I go back in in
this expression here you know we are
we're summing over all Targets but the
point here is that each r r tildei
multiplied by dtldi if at the correct
indices KL for that Target these have
very large values so if you if you just
look at your K hat I
L hat I indices which are the actual
range and Doppler indices for the ice
target all the rest of the terms are
negligible like all the rest of the RTD
tldis are almost zero and you only
extract the RTD TLD for that that Target
so after your target detection you can
ignore the summation you can write at L
hat ik hat I your range Doppler
processed signal is just the RT leading
to the of the ice target times the
spatial phase from the ice target right
again I know the math is is way too
abstract and and kind of can be
overwhelming but let's look at this
picture together I think this is ignore
the math if this makes sense you will
you will get through the math so what we
are visualizing here is that
pre-processed data Cube okay so I'm
showing it as slices because it's hard
to visualize a cube so every slice here
starting from this first one is the
range range velocity or range doppler
map that you get by processing the
signal from one of your virtual antenna
elements okay so the first one is Sif LK
one so one is the antenna index so this
this frontmost one is the range Doppler
from the first antenna then you get it
from the second antenna then you get it
from the antenna number P okay and then
if you look at these range Doppler Maps
remember
actual targets show as Peaks or you know
if it's a heat map like hot zones so in
this one we have two Targets right
that's the first one say that's where
the first Peak is and that's the second
target okay so if for the let's say I
want to find the DOA of the first Target
so I've done my C4 I've found the
what I call the L hat one
and K hats one
of that Target okay now I'm gonna go
through my antenna Dimension so I'm
going to go through the cube and extract
the signal vector
fixing the lnk and just looking at the
value for across the antenna Dimension
what is that equal to it's just equal to
rtd1 K hat one uh
dtld1 L hat one so that's just the range
fft times the the Doppler fft of the of
the first target times this it's a bit
hard to read maybe so let me zoom in
times e to the minus J 2 pi over Lambda
PD sine Theta 1. so if I extract after I
do my target detection if I extract that
basically cross section of the data Cube
across the antenna dimension
uh it's some constant right so this R
times D is now a constant because I
fixed the index but the only thing
that's that's varying as a function of p
is this term which is which has sine
Theta in it okay
so
how do we find uh Theta uh let's uh
introduce a new variable to just
simplify our notation I'm going to call
F Theta I to be equal to 1 over Lambda
sine Theta I that's only to clean up the
notation okay then that signal slice
that we just looked at which is s i f of
L hat i k hat i p as a function of P's
is is given by this this piece ignore it
it's just a constant now
doesn't matter what it is
at all at some constant
what matters I should actually
this piece
what matters is this guy e to the minus
J 2 pi F Theta i p d now it's a function
of p p is my third index of my data Cube
goes from 1 to big p which is the number
of virtual elements and if you look at
this it what is it it's a complex
exponential right would a frequency F
Theta I
that is sampled
especially like a space deer part or if
you want to think in terms of sampling
rate you can call F double Prime of s
which is 1 over D that's your sampling
rate
across the antenna Dimension basically
for the DOA so now I want to estimate F
Theta I because if I find F Theta I I
can take like an arc sine of it and find
Theta I how do I do that well it's a
complex exponential I want to find the
frequency what do we do another Fourier
transform right again we reduce the DOA
estimation to another spectral
estimation or frequency estimation
easiest thing to do is our good old
Fourier transform so
another Fourier transform we do uh one
the P point because the the length of
the signal as a function of Little P
is big p so P point fft of this
pre-processed signal and if you do that
now you can write it as well this we
said is not a function this these two
terms is not a function of P so we are
treating them as a constant the only
thing that comes out is the fft of the
complex exponential term
we call that Theta tilde I of q q is now
at DOA index
right so this fft will show a Peak at
some index called that Q hat I and from
Q hat I we can find our F Theta I which
is what we defined up here what would
that be is just the Q hat I over the
total number of points in the fft times
the sampling rate it's the same thing we
have done for range and velocity we're
just converting the sample in the fft at
the index of the peak in the fft to the
actual frequency why the negative sign
here because it was e to the minus J
that's where the negative sign is coming
from so I find my f hat Theta I but I
want the actual Theta I itself that's
the DOA how do I do that I use this
expression and that gives me Theta hat I
which is minus arc sine of this Q at I
Lambda over p d okay and you're done
that's all you need to do for DOA let's
look at visualization of it one thing
that can happen in and you you can you
can ask why we we didn't talk about it
is in here when we were saying okay
where we have a peak in the range
doppler map that corresponds to the
Target well who says it's just one
target what if you have multiple targets
which have the same range and same
velocity I mean that can happen a lot
especially for stationary targets right
you can have a whole bunch of targets
all at velocity is zero and they're
equidistant from you but they're at
different DOA angles okay would
something break down in that case it
turns out no just naturally our
algorithm handles it and what happens in
that case if you have multiple Targets
in the same range Doppler cell when you
do your third fft in the DOA Direction
you get multiple peaks in it and each
Peak gives you the angle or the DOA of
one of the targets here's what it looks
like so basically again the math gets I
know very you know messy but at the end
of the day the algorithm is extremely
simple you just take your signal after
your range Doppler processing and after
you have done your target detection so
now we're only looking at Target indices
that's why it's l hat ik hat I so you're
looking at ice target essentially you do
a p point fft on it and then that
converts your antenna index to a DOA
index queue and then you find the peaks
of that and then this Q hat ijs those
give you the basically the doas of all
the targets that correspond to that
range and velocity so in this case we
had three targets all with the same
range and velocity and that's fine so
how do you detect the targets again you
have another you know magnitude fft and
you want to find the Peaks you can do
your fixed thresholding or you can do
your
C4 thresholding you know
pick your favorite way of you know
that's a bad drawing of C4 but you get
the idea you find the Peaks after the
the third fft and and you're basically
done that's your full radar DSP pipeline
so
let's summarize everything we talked
about for fmcw radar
and then I'll take questions but but
this is like end to end uh Imaging radar
DSP pipeline from ADC samples to the
full you know fully processed radar Cube
which you can visualize as a point cloud
or an image so how does it work
remember
introduced of of virtual arrays you have
P virtual receive antennas
right
so antenna number one to p and each will
give you after down conversion and if
signal so you get sif1 all the way to
Sif each coming from one of your virtual
antennas and each has two indices right
because we are working with frames of
data and each frame has M chips in it so
little m is the chirp index and little n
is the ADC sample index okay and this
third one that's p is our antenna index
okay so we need three indices for our
data so after you receive these data so
here's like DSP start
thank you
first thing you do is you rearrange your
data into a cube and that's what what
what is is drawn here so you rearrange
it into a cube uh each uh so so row so
one dimension is your chip index M One
Direction Dimension is your ADC sample
index and so this is called the fast
time axis and this is called the Slow
Time axis and the radar literature and
then your third dimension is the antenna
index okay so each little cell in this
data Cube at the end of the day gives
you one ADC sample that's one ADC sample
that you put
into one of those and the entire cube is
one frame of data that you have just
reordered into a cube okay so that now
we can index it with m n and p each cell
of that Cube then you do your range
processing so that's ffts along the rows
okay and you should do it for every
slice right slice by slice row by row
you do your ffts that's your range
processing okay so that would convert
this n index to a range index k
then you do your Doppler processing
that's ffts along the along the columns
right but again you should do it for
every slice right you go to your your
endpoint ffts that would convert your
chip index to a velocity index L okay so
this is our pre-processed data Cube now
big Sif of LK and P
then you do your target detection
pick your favorite algorithm I would
probably do C4 what this does is that
among all the possible else in case it
just gives you the ones that we think
there's Target in them so it just gives
you the L hat i k hat I with actual
Targets in it okay now for this part uh
for for Target detection the 2D C4 just
so that you don't need to do it remember
we get a p number of range Doppler Maps
each slice antenna slice gives you a
range doppler map something that is very
common here just so that you don't need
to do pair slice you know Target
detection is that you can after you do
your range Doppler processing you can
average all those range Doppler
processed uh ffts or the magnitudes of
them across the antennas just so it's
clear what I'm talking about is like in
this picture here
uh you can go average all these range
Doppler Maps together or the amplitudes
of them uh um together these sifs take
the magnitude and average then you get
one average range doppler map and you do
your 2D C4 on that because the idea is
you know the Targets in terms of range
and Doppler are the same regardless of
which antenna you you're looking at so
that's very common
not necessary but commonly done it makes
it more efficient but at the end of the
day you find your range and velocity
indices of your targets you still have
your antenna Dimension and then you do
your DOA processing and that's a p point
fft in the in the third basically
dimension of the data Cube and that
converts your basically antenna Index P
to a DOA index queue okay so now you
have your STD I hat I still the if L hat
ik hat IQ you still need to do one more
Target DOA detection to find like which
of these cues correspond to actual uh
doas of the targets that's another Peak
search you can do a 1D C4 you can do a
constant thresholding whatever you do
after that you pick Q Hat eyes which you
think correspond to actual doas of the
targets now you have basically your DSP
is finished because you have if you have
identified the velocity index the range
index and the DOA index of all Targets
right so I here goes from 1 to K where K
is the total number of targets that you
have in the scene but usually you want
to map these from indices to physical
quantities like range in meters radial
velocity meters per second angle in
radians or degrees so you have this
final step but that's that's just the
scaling we know how it's done right you
take your L hat I I don't know
multiplied by
C divided by FS or something like that
but that just converts your indices to
actual range velocity and and DOA angles
and then you're done then you decide how
you want to visualize it one very common
way is produce a radar image that is a
point Cloud uh if you did a 2d on the
Azimuth only you know DOA you get a 2d
Point cloud or you can do a a 3D Point
Cloud very quickly before we quit for
today here's another picture of you know
another very high level visual way of
looking at it this is an example process
radar data Cube this was the scene so
there was just one person walking and
this is the the already Pros fully
processed data Cube so the axes are our
velocity range and Azimuth angle we
didn't have elevation it was just a 2d
radar and then at this point there's
many visualizations you can generate uh
the one I I I I I mean all of them are
are informative but for instance if you
slice it over the the the the the range
and the Azimuth uh or as a Muslim
velocity axis that's the a yellow slice
it gives you something a 2d heat map
which is called a velocity angle heat
map one axis is velocity one axis is
angle and then The Hot Zone that's
basically where your target is so you
can find its velocity and angle you can
slice it the red slice for instance
gives you the so-called range velocity
heat map again it's all the same
information you're just visualizing it
differently so you can find your target
velocity and range from it and the black
slice is the range range and Azimuth
angle so you find the range of the
Target and the Azimuth angle of the
target from this what you can do is you
can produce a point Cloud what you do is
you basically so this is basically gives
you your target coordinates in in in
polar so it gives you R and Theta
um so so then you can go and put a point
you know in a in a 2d or you can convert
that to Cartesian if you want with doing
like R cosine Theta R sine Theta
and that would be like the X Y
coordinates of your target I might have
mixed up sine and cosine you can figure
it out but then you'll find x y and then
put a dot there if you have more than
one target
then it makes for a more interesting
point Club but that's it that's the full
you know uh full DSP of of of radar at
the end of the day it's really if you if
you were to code all of this everything
you talked about literally and you would
do it in homework too pretty much from
scratch you would see it becomes like
five lines of code because it's just two
F of three ffts and two thresholds it's
literally five lines of python code I
mean I know the math became kind of
dense and and complicated but really
really at the end of the day it's very
simple what's extremely important and I
hope you you you you you go with that
take you from the class is all the
assumptions we made along the way and
also the fact that fft for instance is
just one implementation of of an
algorithm for finding frequencies
there's there's better more
sophisticated algorithms you could do
and that would hugely improve the
performance of of radar questions
all right see you next time